if you thought this summer flying season
was bad you better buckle up at the
labor day weekend nearly 13 million of
you are expected to fly from a u.s
airport that's a big jump from last year
and boy is it going to be a pain in the
you know what so far today more than 3
000 flights are delayed and nearly 150
are cancelled so what's mayor pete going
to do about all this travel chaos not
much apparently biden's transportation
secretary launched a website to see how
airlines treat you when they cancel your
flight and he's also got some airlines
to provide some food and hotel vouchers
but overall nothing to fix the actual
problem delayed and canceled flights
judge uh why do you think all these
flights are being delayed and canceled
well first of all a lot of people are
flying now
a lot of pilots are not flying
and um i just want you to know how happy
i am the buddha judge is on the case
because pete buda judge and the
department of transportation is making
sure
that the rules are followed and he is
expanding the rights of passengers and
if they delay you you get a meal or 10
bucks which will buy you a drink only
and not a meal and then he says he's
contemplating options to write new rules
here's this all i got to say to you you
have to go to the department of
transportation website if your flight is
delayed or if you're waiting on the
tarmac you should get like 300 bucks or
something like that i forget what it is
and it goes you go check on the
dashboard each airline because the
airlines owe you money don't just say
you know gee my airline got canceled you
may be able to get money they're
canceling flights knowing that they'll
just pack the next flight
yeah it's not fun i fly delta way too
much because i would like to be home
more but i work in new york live in
georgia that's the price i pay i don't
mind it i i like flying on delta the
pilots when you get it you want to get
something from delta no we love delta
we're just trying to be judicious here
jessica when we look at mayor pete not
one airline's been fined so far um and
there's an opportunity to do that
the way the rules and regulations are it
was hard for even me to understand but i
guess kind of by law they should offer
you a cash uh a cash voucher back but
they're only offering flights what can
mayor pete do what should he do or what
can he do well it seems like they're it
has to be two-parted one doing something
about what the airlines are doing and
they got tons of bailout money also yeah
you're right i mean this is the question
we're asking you know about what's going
on in schools what's going on with
airlines you get you know
millions and millions and billions of
dollars
spend it properly and make sure that you
have people understand the pilot
training program takes longer than it's
not like just hiring someone off the
street but as you were explaining to me
in the green room they should have been
prepared for this because this was
something that's been brewing for a few
years and then obviously during the
pandemic it kind of hit a higher octane
there so you have to make sure that
people are taken care of give them the
cash vouchers make sure they get meals
hotels i mean that's one of the biggest
problems that people get stranded in a
city where they don't live and then they
have to go rent a hotel room for the
night which you know is not it is not
cheap um so needs to be on both sides of
that well jessica didn't fully answer my
problem here but kaylee i want to ask
you
when we talk about why this is happening
i live in deltaville that's why i'm so
nice to them those are my neighbors all
the people that work on the planes and
fly to planes live there south of the
airport where i'm at and this problem
has been brewing for a while one of the
things that happened was that airlines
took ppp money under the auspice of not
laying anybody off but then they
incentivized their pilots to retire so
they could get them off their payroll
but they took in money they didn't have
to pay back so should these airlines
have to pay some of that ppp money back
yeah i mean it's a great point uh they
tried to have their cake and eat it too
um and that cake happened to be taxpayer
dollars and here we are you know 54
billion dollars later um but don't worry
i mean to the judge's point big bag
buddha judge he's on the case um big bad
buddha judge he made a dashboard for us
this weekend when you think dashboard
you think an interactive website my
flight's delayed let's go on the buda
judge dashboard normally you can't print
a dashboard this is the dashboard it's
literally a chart a poster board that
you would create that has all of the
airlines listed with checks and with x's
as to whether they offer refunds offer
meals this isn't a dashboard
this is like five people in pete's
office who put together something so he
could have a long weekend i hope you're
enjoying your time pete because the rest
of us are looking at your dashboard and
getting no answers
greg the problem goes all the way down
to the supply chain it goes down to
labor i mean they don't have enough
people at atlanta airport to take the
bags off the planes after 10 pm so yeah
and wait for three hours there are
people that own little businesses that
supply parts to these airplanes when
something's mechanical if you put it on
the ground for six months it's gonna
break just sitting there instead of
flying so now you have a backlog of all
this so supply chain is a big part of it
you know apparently the government's
making sure they buy you a hotel room
and give you a meal i mean i think
there's more the government could do i
don't know i mean
look i'm going to have to defend the
biden administration here because i feel
like we could find a segment on this
topic from two years ago five years ago
eight years ago and it will sound
exactly the same whenever you do travel
segments in high peak periods it's all
about cancellations it's all about
complaints and why because nothing ever
changes it's not really just a lack of
preparation it's a lack of innovation in
the airline industry imagine if
computation the computer chip industry
progressed like the airline industry
this phone would weigh four tons to do
the exact same things that i wanted to
our computers would be walls and walls
of wires that's because
somehow the computer industry is
constantly innovating always are
tripling it's it's computer power what
every three years or some crazy thing
we need to start looking at airline
travel in a with a with a with a new
brain there needs to be some new
thinking about this what would you do
well i think that like we know that
smaller plants can go faster maybe they
start making more smaller plants maybe
we start having
these taxi cabs these drones that can
now just
i think like releasing the pressure off
the of the long-haul flights with
shorter flights might work but what do i
know i'm an english major more
connections more or just terrible no i
don't know i mean more direct flights
between small little things and then
electric bikes for everyone
there you go well i'd need three wheels
on my bike so anyway uh listen if you're
sitting at home read the fine print
those airlines owe you more uh than
they're giving you all right coming up
next don't go anywhere the fastest is
right here hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now